I came to you very care.
Fully about two weeks ago, and I told you,
if you compared the polls today.
Now, this was like August 20th.
I said to you on August 20th, if you compare
the polls today to the polls four years ago
between Joe Biden I'm sorry, between Hillary
Clinton and Donald Trump, there was only a
zero point, seven point difference over that
four year period.
And what I said on August 20th was I wouldn't
be super confident with a polling difference
of zero point seven points when we compare
2016 to 2020.
We now have another two weeks of polling data
and we now have a different situation.
Joe Biden today is in a different position
than that in which Hillary Clinton found herself
four years ago today.
So let's look at the numbers.
Then we'll talk about the significance.
Then we'll look at states right now, on average,
according to Real Clear Politics, Joe Biden
is leading Donald Trump nationally by seven
point one.
Now, this is an average.
There are recent polls where Biden is only
up by two.
The latest Emmerson poll is one example.
There are polls where Biden is up by 10.
Like the recent CBS YouGov poll, the latest
USC poll.
But on average, Biden is up seven point one,
OK?
On this day in 2016, meaning September 8th,
2016, Hillary Clinton was leading Donald Trump
by only 2.8 percent.
This is now a different situation.
If you go back four years, Hillary Clinton's
lead was significantly smaller than that of
Joe Biden today.
Now, what does this mean?
Nothing, nothing.
Nothing.
Everyone must vote.
It is simply interesting to consider that
as of today, Joe Biden's lead is 2.5 times
that of Hillary Clinton.
Exactly four years ago.
What are the odds that if Trump loses by seven,
he wins the Electoral College?
They are low, but unless we vote, it means
nothing.
And of course, this is an electoral race which
will come down to a handful of states.
And looking at recent polling, some highlights
from the last five days.
Donald Trump is winning by five in Missouri.
As of yesterday.
Now, why do we care about Missouri?
We care about Missouri because in 2016, Trump
won Missouri by 19.
If Donald Trump were to win Missouri by only
five.
That's not good for him.
In Wisconsin, Biden is up eight in a right
leaning Rasmussen poll and up six in Wisconsin
in a CBS News YouGov poll that was almost
tied in 2016.
Texas has Trump at only plus two, according
to the Dallas Morning News.
Remember that in 2016, Trump won Texas by
nine.
If Trump were to win Texas by only two, that
would be a very interesting signal about the
South.
Joe Biden is currently up 15 in New Mexico.
That would be a wild win in 2016.
Hillary did win New Mexico, but only by eight.
Of course, if Joe Biden doubles his margin
of victory in New Mexico, that would be huge.
One note is in 2016, libertarian Gary Johnson
had nine in New Mexico.
We'll talk about the lack of Gary Johnson
in a moment.
We have a recent Florida poll from the Republican
Trafalgar Group, which has Trump plus three
in Florida.
Florida could be a fight, but we've also got
a Quinnipiac poll from Florida that has Biden
plus three.
Remember, Florida is likely much more important
in the path to 270 electoral votes for Donald
Trump than it is for Joe Biden.
Now, let me go back to what I just mentioned.
Not only do we not have Gary Johnson this
year, we also don't have Jill Stein.
And if you go back and look at the numbers
from 2016, Gary Johnson ended up with a little
over three percent of the vote in 2016 nationally.
Jill Stein ended up with about one percent
of the vote.
Jill Stein's vote alone could it could have
flipped some states from Hillary to Trump
and could be solely responsible for Hillary
Clinton losing and Donald Trump winning electorally.
But with Gary Johnson not pulling three point
two percent of the vote.
We also have to consider the impact of that.
And so anybody saying the third party difference
this year is going to make it very clear that
Trump will win or Trump will lose?
I think we don't know that.
I think everybody has to vote.
I think we've got to count every ballot.
Now, last word of warning.
And this is this is maybe the most important
thing.
The polls, as accurate as they might be about
the intentions of voters, cannot tell us the
effect of voter suppression.
The polls don't tell us the effect of messing
with the postal service.
The polls cannot account for voter purges
that we know are going on and have been reporting
on.
And so this is the really important message.
Biden today with a lead that's two and a half
time.
Larger than Hillary's lead in 2016.
That's a beautiful thing.
That's a great thing.
But it does not account for any of the foul
play.
And if it's close, and especially if Trump
comes out ahead on election night in some
states and then the lead starts to shrink
as absentee ballots are counted in the days
following and it goes more and more to Joe
Biden, Donald Trump will use courts, many
of which are overseen by the judges he installed
to try to stop the counting of absentee ballots.
So is 2.5 X in terms of the lead the the multiple
by which Joe Biden is leading over Hillary
Clinton's lead?
Good for us.
Well, yeah, it's good.
But given all of these other question marks,
I would be far more comfortable if the lead
were bigger and I would be far more comfortable
if I knew we were going to absolutely crush
turnout.
So the messages.
We've got
to vote.